[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen
sallys welt heute gibt ein saisonales
rezept eigentlich wie immer aber heute
gibt maronen suppe schon wieder den
macher zum ersten mal heute war heute
hast schon mal etwas machen dann hast du
mohn gemacht wird ist doch kürbis machst
dann sind deine drei anti
lieblingssachen mit wollen ja weil also
wirklich wagen sind dämonen auszutreiben
nein aber maroden sind super lecker die
kennt die vielleicht vom weihnachtsmarkt
gibt dir immer so laut sie die unten
gerichtet und ein bisschen wirklich
super lecker wobei ich sagen muss dass
sie mir aus dem backofen verschlug
besser schmecken also nicht gerüstet wie
auf dem weihnachtsmarkt weil sie
schmecken einfach schon zu da hat er mit
so viel rauch aroma ich finde aus dem
backofen oder auf dem wasser gut und ich
kenne die aus meiner kindheit in meinen
eltern maronen sammeln gegangen
deswegen jetzt eine maronen super hohen
auch ausstellen werde ich bis heute noch
mit samira und ella sammeln gehen
das vollstellen also früher gemacht er
eisern auto sich war
ich musste meinen eltern früher in
waldhausen sammeln aber genau so geizig
waren es im supermarkt zu kaufen diesem
jahr teuer aber heute nehmen wir auch
gekaufte mache nichts sag ich auch durch
warum ich sag jetzt mal die zutaten für
die suppe frau ist 30 gramm butter 2
zwiebeln 400 gramm maronen 500
milliliter gemüsebrühe finde ich 200
gramm sahne dann jeweils eine prise
zucker und chili etwas pfeffer muskat
salz und noch etwas schwanz zum
abschmecken
und zwar habe ich jetzt hier die
vorgekochten maronen das erleichtert
einfach die arbeit und die gibt's auch
so im supermarkt zu kaufen die sie jetzt
auf der obst und gemüseabteilung und die
sind bereits geschält und vorgekocht das
heißt ich habe ziemlich die arbeit
tietze polen
denn ungekochte maronen die sind einfach
ziemlich schwer zum schälen
deswegen muss die einfach vorher garen
nämlich schon mal die butter
ich nehme sie zwiebeln
und wird die fein hacken
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich die butter in einem topf
den habe ich jetzt bereits erhitzt und
geht auf die zwiebelwürfel mit dazu und
basic classic anbraten
die stufe so ein bisschen zurück stellen
und mit dem herzen und kann in der zeit
schon mal die maronen so ein bisschen
hat
[Musik]
jetzt kommen die marone mit dazu kurz
mit anbraten
da kann ich sie gleich mit der
gemüsebrühe ablöschen und dann mit
verschlossenem decken erstmal etwa 20
bis 30 minuten lang garen bis sie nach
innen weich fit
[Musik]
maron sinne zwar gekocht und ich habe
freunde gewürzt vergessen also chili und
zockereien etwas pfeffer und salz müsste
dann einfach abschmecken
ein bisschen muss gras und gebe jetzt
noch die sahne mit dazu und wer die
suppe jetzt schon mal fein pürieren
[Musik]
so ich werde jetzt in meine suppe noch
ein bisschen wasser geben die schützen
momentan zu dickflüssig sieht man zum
wird so einfach zu lange einkochen
lassen
aber ich habe gar kein problem und wenn
sie dann gleich noch abschmecken und in
der zwischenzeit aber auch noch ein paar
fotos machen und zwar habe ich hier ein
paar brotwürfel und ein bisschen butter
und adressiert drin einfach ein bisschen
rüsten
[Musik]
oliver morath der murat problem
ich werde jetzt aber ich hier noch die
croutons ein bisschen sitzen mit salz
pfeffer und thymian reinmachen schwach
ruhig den verein damit die maroni
schmeckt aber ich muss ehrlich sagen
also nie immer wohnen zufällig gleich
ziemlich etwas stauraum
okay was hat auch perfekt dazu passen
würde wäre ein mit schaum zum beispiel
dann ein paar hätte man sie gegossen
wird so ein typisches weihnachtsessen
finde ich schauen ja ich kann so die
weihnachtsmenü ich probiere jetzt war
deutlich deswegen war sie schon süppchen
für ein weihnachtsmenü katchalov entchen
zusammenfinden süppchen
ok jetzt wäre ich gespannt das ding
alles wegstecken aber nicht schlecht als
man mir alles gut bis sehr gut
also der marienmarkt man also ich finds
die machen ja mal so eine richtig tolle
das wenig dazu sämige konsistenz sehr
viel sich hin
also ich finde jetzt also und ich bin ja
ein richtig tolles aroma ich bin ja das
schmeckt halt anders schmeckt nussig
vielleicht auch ein tropfen war sanikis
ich zum feinschmecker
hier kann man auch mit drauf machen also
eine leichte säure noch mit dabei also
ich schon die super lecker ja als auf
jeden fall wieder isley findet zum
beispiel diese diese taktische jobs
finde ich cool ich nicht besser also es
ist es nicht schlecht weiß ich was essen
aber ich will mir also jeder der maronen
liebt wird diese suppe auch lieben ich
würde auf jeden fall nachmachen und
werdet ihr auch noch einmal nachmachen
und falls ihr das rezept sucht dann
geht's das aussieht - blog.de und ich
wünsche euch ganz in schwarz beim
nachmachen und du wirst dann geht mir
einfach die suppe wirklich in ordnung
lecker aber dafür muss man geboren sein
glaubt motors ins bett ja ich hole zum
döner und ich wünsche euch viel spaß
mache bis dann euer gratis
[Musik]